vamos a tratar de calcular el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 de x al cubo menos 1
entre x cuadrada menos 1 y primero hay
que notar que si sustituimos con x igual
a 1 en esta expresión tendremos 1 al
cubo menos uno que es 0 / 1 al cuadrado
que es 1 menos uno y nos vuelve a dar 0
entonces nos da algo de la forma 0 entre
0 así que veamos si se puede simplificar
este límite utilizando algunas
herramientas algebraicas entonces esta
parte de aquí de lo que estamos la
función de la cual estamos calculando el
límite lo podemos vamos a tratar de
manipular la algebraica mente tenemos x
al cubo menos 1 entre x cuadrada menos 1
entonces lo primero que tú puedes
observar es que el denominador es una
diferencia de cuadrados así que este
fácilmente se puede sustituir por x
menos 1 por x más 1 así es como lo
podemos expresar como un producto de dos
factores ahora bien el problema aquí es
que tenemos en el denominador
x 1 y que es el que nos está dando que
al sustituir con 1 nos dé un 0 en el
denominador así que nos pregunte es
natural o al menos sería una buena
pregunta ver si x al cubo menos 1 tiene
un factor x menos 1 para que se cancele
y ya no nos causen problemas muy bien
entonces este es el que importa porque
nos hace que quede 0 en el denominador
cuando sustituimos con 1 así que vamos a
ver si esto ocurre
veamos si es posible dividir x cúbica
menos 1 entre x menos 1 así que vamos a
intentar esta división de polinomios que
a lo mejor algunos ya están relacionados
con ello y para no hacer mucho problema
vamos a dejar aquí los dos los espacios
de x cuadrada de x y aquí va la
constante menos 1 muy bien entonces nos
preguntamos cuántas veces cabe xx al
cubo y esto es x cuadrada verdad x
cuadrada por x es x al cubo menos 1 por
x cuadrada es
x cuadrada y ahora vamos a restar este
de abajo así que simplemente invertimos
los signos estos se cancelan y nos queda
x cuadrada ahora cuántas veces cabe xx
cuadrada pues cabe x veces verdad x x x
x cuadrada y menos 1 por x es menos x
nuevamente restamos y por lo tanto le
cambiamos el signo estos estos se
cancelan y nos queda x y bajamos el
menos uno ahora cuántas veces cabe x
menos uno en x menos uno pues una vez
verdad entonces uno por x sx1 por menos
uno es menos uno y si cambiamos los
signos otra vez nos queda un residuo de
cero y eso fue muy bonito porque
entonces x al cubo menos 1 lo podemos
expresar como x menos 1 que multiplica a
x cuadrada más x + 1 ahora notemos que
cuando x es distinto de 1 estos dos se
pueden cancelar y por lo tanto esta
expresión me queda como x cuadrada más
x + 1 / x 1 entonces este límite de aquí
será exactamente el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 de esto que obtuvimos que es
x cuadrada + x + 1 / x + 1 ok entonces
este es muy agradable porque arriba y
abajo ya nos dan cosas que son distintas
de cero de hecho si sustituimos arriba
con 1 nos queda 1 al cuadrado que es uno
más uno más uno y esto nos da
simplemente tres y este de abajo es uno
más uno y nos da dos así que el
resultado es tres medios